alright so if you're like me you have
invested so much time in the Mass Effect
trilogy and now you've beaten Mass
Effect 3 and you hate the ending so I'm
here to tell you what I think about the
Mass Effect 3 endings why I think the
endings suck and what they might have
been able to do to make them better or
so first of all my big issue with the
Mass Effect 3 endings is choice or lack
thereof the Mass Effect trilogy builds
up the fact of what you do affects what
happens in the game the Mass Effect 3
ending goes against that entirely so in
the end of Mass Effect we talked to some
star child who says all right you have
one of three options you can either
control the Reapers you can feed
synthetics and organics together or you
can destroy all synthetic life in the
galaxy those are your three options to
that I say [ __ ]
why are those my only three options
first of all talking with this kid you
don't actually have dialogue that's Mass
Effect dialogue you just kind of hear
him talk to you where's the dialogue
circle how can I ask him the questions I
need to ask him how can I tell him to go
[ __ ] off and everything I know about
Commander Shepard renegade or Paragon
doesn't matter if this star child's like
oh you can either do this this or this
Commander Shepard would be like no
[ __ ] how about we've earned the
right to shut the Reapers down not
destroy all synthetic life in the galaxy
but just shut them down I suppose you
could do that if you've established that
the Reapers have their own code oh wait
they did so destroy that code and shut
them down no that's just not a viable
option apparently because you did
everything right in the game now people
have told me and it is said that there
are sixteen different endings in Mass
Effect 3 I guess technically if by 16
different endings you mean one ending
that is 95 percent the same ending and
very slightly in certain parts and every
one of the endings this happens energy
goes out hits the Reapers takes the
Reapers down energy hits the mass relay
mass relay sends it to another mass
relay mass relays all blow up shockwave
chases the Normandy Normandy Maroons on
a planet that is every single ending in
the game after that little things very
like whether or not Big Ben gets
destroyed whether or not the earth gets
incinerated whether or not you stop the
Reapers by taking control of them
whether or not you fused organic and
synthetic life together in the end
commander shepard dies and all that
[ __ ] happens right now people are
typing on the keyboards going over julie
commander shepard lives no he doesn't he
dies in every ending by commander
shepard living you mean that one scene
where it pans over to someone's chest
and he takes half a breath and it cuts
two credits that's not Commander Shepard
living that's some stupid Easter Egg in
which they're not committed to the fact
that he died that's like Magneto moving
the little chess piece at the end of
x-men 3 just commit
he lives and he comes out he's hugging
all his friends he's like yeah we did it
or he dies in which case he's will now
dead on this half-assed breathe one half
a breath cut two credits [ __ ] and
here is another big issue I have with
the game apparently Bioware didn't think
the whole thing through about
consequences and repercussions of the
ending you know since they've built
three games all built around
consequences and repercussions the mass
relays blow up there are no more mass
relays in which case that entire Armada
you brought in to war to fight the
Reapers are all stranded on earth earth
which we don't have the resources to
sustain that huge Galactic Armada if it
was in its prime if the Reapers didn't
leave it looking like this now you have
a zillion different people and a few
different species all stranded on earth
with no resources and no mass relays to
go get resources couple things about
that that is telling me in the best
ending possible the best case scenario
everyone who came to war with you that
entire Galactic Armada they're all going
to starve to death on earth and die good
job fighting the Reapers man that's your
big payment
everyone's dead and screwed I mean the
Krogan platoon is going to be over here
raping and killing for dominance the
turians are going to start starving
they're going to start eating the humans
the humans are going to start starving
they're going to start eating themselves
turn to cannibalism and then and
everyone's going to starve to death and
die that's just the reality of the
situation also if all the mass relays
are destroyed what's the point in
uniting the galaxy yeah yeah the Krogan
tend the turians patched-up their
conflict that's good Oh too bad they're
never going to see each other ever again
because there are no more mass relays it
just makes uniting the galaxy and
putting all those conflicts to rest
absolutely pointless people have said
that human beings do get interstellar
travel back and mass relays because at
the very very end of the game it shows
the old guy talking to the kid on a
planet that's clearly not earth but that
could be one of a hundred things maybe
that old guy is like a great great great
great grand kid of a couple of humans
that were on the asari planet and now
they're still there maybe after the
Normandy marooned on that planet that's
like the distant descendents so that's
the thing nothing's set in stone it's
all theory one ending that's tweaked
like 16 different ways to be kind of
different but really not in which no one
knows the definitive meaning of it
everyone has theories and questions
that's a problem maybe that was
Bioware's plan to get people talking
about the ending on line but that's just
a cheap-ass thing to do
now I've heard some theories about well
maybe the endings just indoctrination he
just dreamed the whole thing I would be
fine in buying that if that was one of
the endings one of the possible bad
endings but in the end it just feels
like people are grasping for
drawers to find anything that is not the
ending that they got which i think is
really sad that's people going oh maybe
it was just all the dream you mean you
would rather have a dream that didn't
happen rather than the ending you did
have B fact yes that doesn't depress
anyone else if you're gonna boast about
sixteen different endings being in the
game make them vastly different oh yeah
make one ending be the ending you get
where the mass relays I'll blow up
everyone's stranded on earth the entire
galaxies cut off from each other
that'll be our bad ending but maybe have
another ending where if you gave the
Illusive man the collector--base maybe
he lives and maybe he's on trial for war
crimes and you and anderson are there
just thrown the book at him and for
God's sakes give us a good ending I
understand the common belief is that in
epics like these the hero has to die but
the phrase the hero has to anything in a
game like Mass Effect that's built
around choice and you pick in your own
destiny it goes against everything that
Mass Effect is all about if someone
plays good for the entire time they
should earn a good ending you know show
what's happening with your crews show
Shepard and Gareth on a beach they're
talking with each other
Jeffers like well we did it Garris we
took back earth scaris is all like you
took it back Shepard because I was there
and I had your back what would you do
without me you know they have banter
back and forth because they're really
strong war buddies and then you see the
beefs that they're looking at and it's a
beach but you see like big dead Reapers
sticking out of the water and they're
like well it's going to take some work
but we took earth back maybe have
another ending that goes across the
galaxy shows the death and the quarians
working together it shows the terrains
and the Krogan shaking hands show that
what you did in the game mattered the
fact that you brought the galaxy
together is still relevant not just
negated make sixteen completely distinct
and different endings based on what you
have done in your saga that is what
people wanted we wanted to see what
happened to our crew we have grown to
love the characters so show resolution
with our characters not just all the
crew got stranded on a planet somewhere
no dialogue that just happened another
there speaking of the Normandy getting
stranded on a planet why was Joker
running from the fight I mean Joker's
flying the Normandy with your crew in it
away from the battle they get marooned
on a planet somewhere off in the galaxy
which means they hit the mass relay
before you made your choice and blew up
the mass relays in which case Shepard is
near death limps to the end of the game
gets up to the Citadel and Joker was
like all right crew come on peace were
out they would not do that your crew
would not leave you at the end of the
battle they would stick with you to the
end no matter what choice you made I
just find that a violation of all the
characters of
our crew so here it is ei Bioware if
you're watching this the people have
invested a lot of time and money into
the saga that you've given them you owe
them a solid ending you owe them what
you promised them which is 16 different
endings not one ending that's 95% the
same - a couple tweaks here and there
we're asking for DLC content we're
asking that you fix this right now and
free DLC we already bought the game give
us the ending we paid for and God forbid
that's not going to work people out
there of the 76,000 subscribers I have
if someone knows how to program code can
you make a new ending or a few different
endings please if you can make a new
ending that would be golden doesn't even
have to have dialogue just make it like
the end of Mass Effect 2 or it just
shows Shepard walking through and all
those crews nodding at him like yeah we
did it so that's what I feel about it
that is what I feel about the endings to
Mass Effect 3 or ending there are
petitions out there that you can sign
that are pretty much like no those
endings do not count give us what we
deserve I put a few of them below if you
want to go check them out sign them now
this is one of these scenarios I can
tell you I can promise you this is going
to happen right when I upload this video
I'm going to start thinking the things
that I forgot to say in this video that
I still adamantly feel irrelevant so if
you think it's something that I didn't
mention in this video comment below tell
me about it make a video about it put it
as a video response to this video I'll
accept it and show this to EA or Bioware
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you